ja es klingt wie ein schlechter witz die
betriebskrankenkasse schwenningen will
einer rollstuhlfahrerin keine neuen
rollstuhl reifen bezahlen die begründung
die fahrerin sei mit ihrem elektro mit
rolli statt sechs ganze 10 km h gefahren
dadurch hätten sich die gummireifen
stärker abgenutzt als normal
und deshalb würde man nicht bezahlen es
ist kein witz sondern für kerstin sander
ist das bittere realität und sie ist mir
jetzt zugeschaltet kerstin sander ganz
herzlich willkommen bei bild ja da kann
man nur den kopf schütteln bei dieser
begründung der krankenkasse wir haben
sie denn reagiert als sie die begründung
erfahren haben
ich war völlig fassungslos ich heiße und
solange rollstuhl aber so was ist wenn
du nie passiert ich bekommen
elektrorollstuhl das ist ein leben
teilhaben kann
und jetzt werden doch 2,5 kilometer und
emittiert und das wollte ich mir einfach
nicht gefallen lassen dass wir so vieles
nehmen aber meine mobilität und meine
freie hand und damit ihre mobilität
nicht genommen wird nicht ihre
lebensqualität genommen wird da ist der
zulieferer für ihren rollstuhl
eingesprungen hat das geld erst mal
tatsächlich vorgeschossen möchte es
natürlich aber auch wieder bekommen
was hat die krankenkasse erweiterte
ihnen gesagt sie haben ja sicher gesagt
leute das ist doch nicht euer ernst
kann man dazu sagen die blind alles
abgeschafft probieren ich habe für
meinen geschmack an die öffentlichkeit
es war alles keine rolle
sie beharren auf ihre meinung
und ich konnte nicht bewegen umzustimmen
und es geht ja nicht darum dass sie gar
nicht mehr die reifen bezahlen wollen
sie haben ja glaube ich auch gesagt also
die krankenkasse dass sie die nächsten
reifen wieder bezahlen würden also das
klingt dann doch schon sehr nach
schikane was wünschen sie sich denn von
ihrer krankenkasse jetzt dass das
gefällt wird das ist nicht ihr dass man
kämpfen muss und es kann nicht sein dass
sich entwickler um streifen so ein
theater schon fühlen muss das kann alles
haben die ganzen jahre punkten auf
einmal mit alles gestoppt und wir werden
natürlich ihren fall weiter begleiten
werden schauen was dabei rauskommt wenn
wir jetzt darüber berichten in der bild
zeitung gibt es heute einen artikel über
ihren fall der fassungslos zurück
gelöste und wir hören da natürlich nach
bei der krankenkasse und drücken ihnen
die daumen dass sie sich da die ja die
menschen da noch bewegen bei der
krankenkasse und auch geld dann zahlen
für ihre reifen ganz herzlichen dank
dass sie ihren fall geschildert haben
kerstin sander
ganz herzlichen dank